Stephen hawking geht mit einem knall ab als am 14 märz starb, hinterließ er vielleicht seine
Bahnbrechende arbeit es wäre ein geniestreich eine theorie von paralleluniversum wir könnten sie hier in unserem universum
Bestätigen gemeinsam mit dem belgischen physiker thomas hartung soll er eine
Multiversum theorie entwickelt und jetzt wurde sie veröffentlicht und ist damit peer reviewed worden also, wissenschaftlich
Nicht zu beanstanden jetzt also alles über die letzte arbeit von stephen hawking krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Während der arbeiten an dieser theorie hatte der belgische physiker thomas herzog schon das gefühl dass es vielleicht die letzte arbeit
von stephen hawking sein könnte die kommunikation wurde immer schwieriger
aber er hat das gefühl dass hawking noch nicht sterben wollte jedenfalls nicht vor der fertigstellung
Dieser arbeit dieses gebiet und seine arbeit daran sei das gebiet auf das er am meisten stolz gewesen sein hawking und er
Überprüfen in der arbeit mit modernen mathematischen methoden die inflation des universums nach dem urknall also die
schlagartige ausdehnung in den bisherigen theorien gibt es eine unendliche
inflation des universums zitat die übliche theorie der ewigen inflation sagt voraus dass unser universum global wie ein
unendliches fraktal ist mit einem mosaik aus verschiedenen taschen universum getrennt durch einen aufblenden
Ozean so hawking in einem interview
Im letzten jahr herzog und hawking sagen jetzt aber voraus dass es anders ist demnach gibt es diese taschen von angenommenen
Bewohnbaren universum so gar nicht die annahme dass es
unterschiedliche universum gebe manche leer manche voller materie manche die nur kurz existieren und nur in unserem universum wäre
zufällig leben möglich diese annahme sei nach ihrer arbeit falsch mit der stringtheorie
Widerlegen sie jetzt die theorie der ewigen inflation nach ihrer theorie ist vieles viel einfacher demnach gibt es diese
Verschiedenen universen gar nicht sondern sie sind alle ähnlich zu unserem universum herzog dazu
das rätsel warum leben gerade wir in einem speziellen universum
wo alles schön ausbalanciert ist für die komplexität und die möglichkeit leben zu entwickeln
Das konnten hawking und er nicht glauben sie rechneten alles durch und kam zu der bahnbrechenden theorie der multi wersen die und jetzt kommt es
Überprüft werden kann wenn ihre theorie stimmt dann müssen die gravitationswellen die vom ende der anfänglichen schnellen inflation unseres universums
Ausgegangen sind darauf hinweisen es wäre ein rauchender colt der untersucht werden können allerdings haben die gravitationswellen
Sehr lange wellenlängen die mit den aktuellen niveau gravitations sektoren nicht gemessen wird können aber die europäische
weltraumagentur esa plant einen viel größeren gravitationswellen detektor und zwar viel viel
größer
Im weltraum er soll zwischen erde und sonne
Gebaut werden und zwar an dem punkt an dem sich die gravitation der beiden gestirne aufgibt der erste test satellit wurde bereits erfolgreich
Ausgesetzt das laser interferometer space antenna system kurz lisa wird aus drei
satelliten bestehen die jeweils achtung
2,5 millionen kilometer voneinander entfernt sind beim nike und dem aktuellen gravitationswellen detektor liegt die länge der aber bei vier
Kilometern es werden bei einem gravitationswellen detektor ja die interferenzen zwischen zwei
im 90 grad winkel zueinander verlaufenden laserstrahlen gemessen werden sie durch eine gravitationswellen
durchlaufen ändert sich jeweils die raumzeit der beiden strahlen
unterschiedlich werden sie dann miteinander abgeglichen bilden sie interferenzen bei einer entfernung von
2,5 millionen kilometern ist dieser
gravitationswellen elektro viel empfindlicher
da sich die verformung der raumzeit auf solange entfernung fiel deutlicher aus wirkt der start des systems ist für
2034 vorgesehen dann erfahren wer vielleicht schon bald wie ob und in welchem
multiversum wir leben wenn er als erstes neues nationen zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp
oder bei teno gramm oder nimmt mit mir über instagram oder facebook
Messenger kontakt auf dafür hier klicken dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom 19 täglich garantiert ihr könnt doch
direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mitbestimmen
Was hier wirklich passiert kriegt also hier drauf in der begrüßungs nachricht ist übrigens ein kleines goodie versteckt und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken hawking sagt weltuntergang voraus ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann